[Music]
Zarah and zen were all excited to
perform a series of tests on a few
solutions to find out whether they
acidic or basic their teacher handed a
few yellow colored paper strips and
before she could return to guide them
Zen had already dropped a few drops of
some solution on it and to his surprise
the paper turned bright red both Zahra
and Zen were confused with this magic
how did the paper turn red the teacher
returned and explained that the two had
performed one of the detector tests they
were supposed to detect whether the
solutions given are acidic or basic and
since the yellow paper changed color and
turned red it indicated that one
solution was tested but how does this
paper tell us the nature of the solution
do you remember understanding the
concept of indicators in the previous
video these are nothing but substances
that help us detect whether the given
solution is acidic or basic without
having to taste it so is this yellow
paper an indicator yes it is and what
does this made up of it's simply a
blotting paper with turmeric applied to
it turmeric yes it is the same turmeric
that's used in the kitchen turmeric is
an excellent indicator to detect the
acidic or basic nature of the solutions
in this case the paper turned red when
the solution was poured onto it so what
did the indicator tell us it clearly
indicated that the solution was basic
yes alkaline substances or solutions
turn turmeric into a red color more the
basic nature brighter the red color will
be and what about acids acids have no
color change when tested with turmeric
the color of turmeric which is yellow
remains unchanged the solution remains
unaffected
that is how turmeric helps differentiate
between acids
and basis assets remain unaffected while
basic solutions turned red and there are
more natural substances that can be used
as indicators yes there are many in the
list next let's look at two more natural
indicators which help in detecting the
acidic and the alkaline nature of
solutions
[Music]